video games are great fun except for
those occasional moments when they
totally stink is there anything worse
than playing an awesome game I mean to
have it totally derailed by a single
moment of pure idiocy here's a look at
some video games almost ruined by one
cutscene Sonic the Hedgehog
one of the biggest facepalms and video
game history took place in 2006 is Sonic
the Hedgehog
thanks for the infamous cast between
princess Elise and Sonic taking center
stage at the cringe Olympics nonsensical
plot developments are usually fine
especially in a fun platformer like this
quotation marks on the fun but this we
had fanfic romance between a human and a
hedgehog was just a little bizarre
[Music]
Super Mario Brothers 2 there's no
denying Super Mario Brothers 2 is
insanely fun classic the many different
worlds and enemies in this place or gave
it loads of character and the players
can have a great time digging up sand or
throwing eggs at Berto and piloting
supporting characters like toad and
Princess Peach but then you get to the
end and well this happens yes it was all
a dream
congratulations you just completely
wasted your time
same throw the third considering you can
fire octopi onto people's heads to make
them dance the silly and slop sticky
same throw to third seems tough like a
goofy over-the-top Joyride and they're
usually it is that's why it's so jarring
when beloved character Johnny cats
abruptly gets after during a mission
Johnny were about the job
talk about the total mood-killer
bayonetta there's fanservice and then
that's just a weird achiness that line
wasn't blurred so much it obliterated at
the end of the action classic bayonetta
we're victorious gamers are treated to a
three-minute dance number called let's
dance boys featuring the titular heroin
just flouncing around for your enjoyment
don't worry it's totally natural to feel
ashamed after playing this game Kingdom
Hearts - at least a done sequence in
Kingdom Hearts 2 has one thing going for
it there's no sign of Bayonetta but
that's the only good thing we can say
about the horrible swim this way musical
number that features Sora dancing with
the cast of The Little Mermaid no just
snow The Legend of Zelda Skyward Sword
there's a lots of love in the classic
Zelda game Skyward Sword but there's
also grouse for whatever reason this
caricature of a bully from the 80s shows
up and chases down link after descending
from Skyloft then players after sit
through several minutes of groose
grunting & hooting about himself his new
world and all sorts of other annoying
crap
just let us get on with saving Zelda
already starting for get ready to
scratch your noggin and confusion that
one of the most awkward cutscenes of all
time courtesy of Star Ocean forth
private action system these are cut
scenes you can trigger to raise your
affection level with specific Party
members that's fine but the creepily
childlike level who is actually 15 years
old gets a little too affectionate edgy
I want to take nappy time with you okay
huh even the other characters in the
game are visibly uncomfortable with how
creepy she is and ascender off to our
own room instead yikes
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to